men this like perception that the  average girl is actually super super hot  because if we look at how many  relationships are struggling because the  guy likes random girls pictures on the  internet and also how many women are  comparing themselves to other women on  instagram what do you think about that  i'm curious  of which part a man liking a woman's  pictures on instagram  it's contextual based on what the  picture is who the woman is like if it's  a friend that he met before me who  happens to be a female who happens to be  a girl totally fine if it's a baddie on  that on the on the scroll page whatever  you call it  that he's never seen before from  america yeah i don't i don't think  that's okay